[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña gabriel ben tasgal analista
político especializado en medio oriente
para hablar sobre lo que está pasando en
israel y las milicias palestinas de gaza
donde los ataques de lado y lado se han
intensificados del pasado 3 de mayo los
peores en años o por lo menos desde el
año 2014 gabriel gracias por estar
nuevamente con nosotros aquí en francés
24 buen día empiezo preguntándole qué
factores llevaron a que esta atención
entre ambos volviera a estallar
el factor fundamental es que la
autoridad palestina había prometido
llamar a elecciones para mayo para el
parlamento y para la presidencia cosa
que no hacía el 2005 el 2006 las
encuestas daban claramente que ganaba
hamás que domina solamente la franja de
gaza pero que aspira a dominar
cisjordania mahmud abás canceló las
elecciones y eso provocó la ira de hamás
que pensaba vencer y la ira se traduce
en de hecho lo que usted están viendo
las imágenes de france 24 ahora gabriel
palestinos denuncian que cada vez más
están siendo expulsados de jerusalén
human right watch llegó a denunciar que
las políticas de israel hacia los
palestinos son crímenes de apartheid
cuál es la situación actual del barrio
donde está ocurriendo todo esto
bueno lo que estás diciendo es la mecha
una de las mechas que encendió la
violencia porque el barrio que nombras
es sexy que es un barrio del norte de
jerusalén que las propiedades eran
propiedades de judíos que las compraron
pero vivían inquilinos árabes que no
pagaron el alquiler y que hicieron
transformaciones en la vivienda y la
justicia israelí decidió ordenar su
desalojo eso fue interpretado por hamás
como que los judíos querían judeizar la
ciudad y además imágenes de 'tik tok' de
personas golpeando a judíos ortodoxos
que fueron subidos a las redes sociales
y eso provocó una reacción de la extrema
derecha en el mes de ramadán todo lo que
te acabo a contar ahora es la mecha que
encendió un problema más grave ahora el
malestar ya no solo está en los
territorios palestinos sino que también
se ha extendido a la población árabe en
las ciudades de israel cómo afecta esto
al conflicto actual y también el
presidente israelí habla de un pogromo
mira afecta y realmente mal porque lo
que estábamos viendo los últimos años
era una sensación de integración o sea
los árabes de israel que es el 20% de
población anunciaba su deseo de
integrarse y de formar parte del
gobierno y de pronto ocurre esta crisis
y de focos determinados de la población
árabe israel en luz y en aquí vemos las
imágenes que usted están viendo ahora en
vuestra televisión o sea veíamos que
había un proceso de integración y esto
que vemos ahora contradice no es buena
noticia los intentos de netanyahu por
formar el gobierno han fracasado y lo
han dejado debilitado alguna manera
podría estar aprovechando esto para
fortalecer su figura con los
enfrentamientos
yo no dudo que esta situación favorece
la imagen interna de netanyahu por otro
lado la posibilidad que la oposición a
ventaneado forme gobierno era o es aún
muy alta lo que pasa es que los partidos
árabes eran los que tenían que darle el
voto de confianza a esta coalición
alternativa con esta crisis que vemos
ahora se resquebraje un poco la
posibilidad de que puedan formar este
gobierno justamente por tu pregunta
anterior
ahora varía el del lado palestino hamás
también busca asentar su liderazgo
frente a la autoridad nacional palestina
de mahmud abás como usted lo está
diciendo dónde más un poco sobre este
tema y cómo lo quieren hacer ellos
viste la serie fauda te toco no tienes
que verla la serie falda muestra como la
autoridad palestina y el servicio
inteligencia israelí colaboran para
poder evitar que hamas haga un golpe de
estado jamás ya hizo un golpe de estado
la franja de gaza y tomó el poder en el
año 2007 significa que hay mucha
colaboración en tema de seguridad
entre autoridad palestina cual es lo que
lo diferencia la autoridad palestina
fuera de un tema territorial que uno
gobierna cisjordania y otra franja de
gaza lo que las diferencias que uno
quiere imponer un califato islámico
hamas y la autoridad palestina no
gabriel gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros empresas 24 por supuesto
queda pendiente de la próxima vez para
conversar un poco más entonces sobre
esta serie que tenga un feliz resto de
día y nosotros hasta aquí llegamos con
este programa de cinco minutos hasta una
próxima oportunidad
[Música]